MEETING TO ORDER --
STARTED IF YOU GO AHEAD AND
NOTIFY THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT THE ONE THIRTY
START TIME HAS COME AND GONE IT
IS TIME TO COME TO WORK.
WE WILL BEGIN --
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE HAVE
TIME TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LOOKING AT THE SIGN IN SHEET IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE NUMBER ONE ON
OUR DOCKET SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR YOU ARE.
HERE ARE PREPARED --
TO WHILE US WITH THE LATEST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
APPRECIATE THAT --
CHAIR --
IT'S ALWAYS MY GOAL --
MY MAIN WITNESSES ON ITS WAY --
OKAY GREAT THEY ARE OKAY --
ANYWAY.
I MEMBERS CHAIR MEMBERS THIS
BILL SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE GOOD WORK
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE
[inaudible]
RECOGNIZING THAT CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO A PHENOMENAL SET OF
SMALL BATCH ARTISAN CRAFT
DISTILLERS [inaudible]
AND UP UNTIL A FEW YEARS AGO WE
WERE WOEFULLY BEHIND MANY OTHER
STATES NEW YORK UTAH AND OTHERS
COLLOREDO.
IN REALLY PROMOTING OUR PARTISAN
DISTILLERS AND WHAT I FOUND KIND
OF INTERESTING ABOUT THAT IS
THAT THOSE DISTILLERS JUST IN
THE SAME ARE SORT OF CALIFORNIA
FARM TO TABLE MOVEMENT.
WHERE WE HAVE CELEBRATED OUR
WINERIES OUR --
OUR RESTAURANTS THAT FEATURE OUR
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS MANY PER
CRAFT DISTILLERS USE CALIFORNIA
SOURCED INGREDIENTS AND THEIR
DISTILLED PRODUCT REALLY
FEATURES THAT.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IN THAT ONGOING SUPPORT IS.
ELIMINATES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
CONSUMERS MUST DO IT TASTING
PRIOR TO THEIR ABILITY TO
PURCHASE AT THAT STORY THEY
LEGISLATURE'S RD ALLOW THEM TO
PURCHASE THE PRODUCT AT THE
DISTILLERY.
BUT UP INTO TOLD TODAY USE ALSO
MUST DO THE TASTING.
AND AS WE KNOW SOME PEOPLE MADE
FOR WHATEVER REASON ON THAT
PARTICULAR DAY NOT BE ABLE TO DO
A TASTING SO WE WANT TO ALLOW
THEM TO AT LEAST BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE PRODUCT IF THEY'RE
MISSING.
IT ALSO INCREASES BY SMALL
AMOUNT THE MAXIMUM VOLUME THAT
HE CRAFT DISTILLER CAN
MANUFACTURE OR PRODUCE IN ORDER
TO BE CONSIDERED A CRAFT
DISTILLER.
AND IT MAKES SEVERAL CLARIFYING
IN MINOR CHANGES TO THE TYPES
SEVENTY FOUR LICENSE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
TESTIFY.
MY CRAFT DISTILLER WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ARTISANAL DISTILLERS GUILD I AM
ALSO A MEMBER --
IONE DRY DIGGINGS AND AMADOR
DISTILLERY.
AND LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR
US OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS AND
READER REITERATE THE NEED. FOR
SOME OF THESE CHANGES AS WE
CONTINUE TO GROW AS AN INDUSTRY
WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'D LIKE TO TURN --
THAT THE TABLE OVER --
TO WE HAVE LANCE --
WITH ST GEORGE SPIRITS AND WE
HAVE NO CAN FROM A GREEN BAR
DOWN LOS ANGELES [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON [inaudible]
CHAIR.
COMMITTEE --
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME --
MONEY WAS LANCE WINNERS I'M THE
MASTER DISTILLER AND THE
PROPRIETOR OF SAINT GEORGE
SPIRITS --
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
NOT JUST OF THE BILL BUT OF
SENATOR SKINNER --
THE SB --
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR GOES GOES
FURTHER AS THE SENATOR VERY
ELOQUENTLY POINTED OUT TO BE
ABLE TO HELP THE THE WORK THAT
WAS ALREADY STARTED IN
ESTABLISHING THE TYPES OF THE
FOR LICENSE --
OUR INDUSTRY IS CONSTANTLY
CHANGING THERE'S A LOT OF
CONSOLIDATION IS TAKING PLACE AT
THE DISTRIBUTOR LEVEL WE LIVE
AND DIE BY WHAT OUR
DISTRIBUTORS.
TO BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE THE INCREASE ON ON THAT THE
NUMBER OF GALLONS ALLOWABLE FOR
TYPES OF THE FOUR PROVIDES.
IS THE ABILITY FOR A CRAFT
DISTILLER TO REACH A LEVEL OF
ECONOMIC SAFETY AND SURETIES --
AND SO THAT BY THE TIME THE UP
BY A DISTRIBUTOR THEY KNOW THEY
CAN MAKE IT TO THAT PLACE --
IT SAID IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE VERY HELPFUL IN CREATING JOBS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALLOWING THESE DISTILLERIES W.
YET TO BE STABLE ENTITIES --
IT DOES PROVIDE SOME GREATER --
GREATER LATITUDE FOR CREATIVITY
BY ALLOWING THE IMPORT OF
CERTAIN PRODUCTS TO BE ABLE TO
BE PLANTED AT THE DISTILLERY'S
WHICH IS ALSO VERY HELPFUL --
AND THEN PROVISIONS THAT WERE.
THERE WERE INCIDENTALLY TAKEN
AWAY WHEN THE TYPES OF BEFORE
WAS CREATED THAT WOULD ALLOW --
CRAFT DISTILLER TO BE ABLE TO DO
TASTINGS IN RETAIL ACCOUNTS
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT OTHER --
DISTILLED SPIRITS PRODUCERS HAVE
THAT WE HAD BEFORE WE BECAME A
TYPE --
SEVENTY FOUR AS WELL AS THE
ABILITY --
TO TO CONTRIBUTE TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE LAST
THIRTY SIX YEARS OF OUR HISTORY
AT STANFORD SPIRITS BEING ABLE
TO BE.
GOOD MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITIES
BEING ABLE TO MAKE DONATIONS TO
HELP SUPPORT THESE NONPROFITS
AND WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT ABILITY COME BACK WHICH IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR HELPS US TO DO
--
SO I I I HOPE THAT YOU CAN GIVE
US YOUR VERY THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION AND THAT.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL FORWARD THANK
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU EVERYONE.
WELL AMERICAN BECAUSE OR BEYOND
COFOUNDER AND SPIRITS MAKE RIGHT
GREEN BAR SILVERY.
WHERE FOURTEEN YEAR OLD CRAFT US
THAT THE READ WITH THE FIRST IN
LOS ANGELES SINCE PROHIBITION
AND ONE OF THE OLDEST IN THE
COUNTRY?
AND I AGAIN OR YOU KNOW ALONG
WITH LANCE AND CHRIS WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS TO
ALLOW US TO BECOME.
A BETTER MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND TO ENGAGE OUR
COMMUNITIES IN WHAT WE DO. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'M REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT A GREEN BAR IS
SHARING WHAT WE DO.
WITH OUR CUSTOMERS AND WITH IT
WITH A COMMUNITY OF ENTHUSIASTS
THAT PATRONIZE US.
AND AS WITH CRAFT BREWERS AS
WITH FAMILY WINEMAKERS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO REALLY
EMBRACES.
OPENING US UP TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE VERY CURIOUS AND VERY
INTERESTED IN WHAT CRAFT
DISTILLING IS ALL ABOUT.
IT ALONG WITH EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT WE CAN DRINK THE HAS GONE
FROM MASS PRODUCTION TO CRAFT.
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE VERY CURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY IT TAKES TO
MAKE SPIRITS YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
MAKE IT WHO MAKES IT ONE OF THE
INGREDIENTS THAT GO INTO IT. FOR
WANT OF FROM OUR LOCAL FARMS AND
ALLOWING US TO HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HAVING TASTING
ROOMS THAT ARE NOT JUST IN THE
BUILDINGS BUT CLOSE BY.
WOULD LLOW US THAT FURTHER
INTERACTION MEMBERS OF OUR OF
OUR ENTHUSIAST COMMUNITIES TO
REALLY ENGAGE WITH US AND
UNDERSTAND.
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT --
WHAT WHAT THE SALARIES DO THE
SECOND THING THAT I WANT TO WITH
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TO EMBRACES
ALLOWING THE INDUSTRY TO INVEST
IN CALIFORNIA DISTILLERIES WITH
A LITTLE BIT MORE LATITUDE?
THERE ARE --
AS LANCE SAID HEATING INCREDIBLE
AMOUNTS OF CONSOLIDATION IN THE
IN THE DISTRIBUTION WORLD WHICH
WHICH MAKES THE THE BAR TO
BECOME A MEANINGFUL CUSTOMER OF
THEIRS VERY HIGH.
AND AS WE ATTEMPT TO GROW AND
BECOME A BETTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY AND CONTRIBUTE MORE
JOBS AND MORE TAXES TO OUR TO
OUR STATE.
WE NEED TO HAVE SMART MONEY
INVESTED IN IN DISTILLERIES AND
ALLOW US TO GROW.
ALLOWING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY OF THE OF THE SELLING
COMMUNITY TO INVEST IN SMALL
CALIFORNIA DISTILLERIES.
WELL OUR MEMBERS TO GROW AND
OUTPACE MEMBERS OF OTHERS AL OF
OTHER STATES AND ALLOW ARE
INDUSTRY HERE TO FLOURISH JUST
AS CRAFT DISTILLERY GREAT
JUSTICE CRAFT BREWERS HAVE
FLOURISHED.
AND AS FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF
FLOORS CLOSER TO THINGS ARE
REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO TO
THINK ABOUT AND AND TO CONSIDER
AND AS PART OF THIS BILL.
THANK OKAY THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY I HAD SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
MEMBERS IN THE QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS WATER RATES.
I'VE GOT A QUESTION.
JUST IN THE HISTORY ON THIS
ISSUE.
OBVIOUSLY WE CREATED THE TYPES
ON FOR LICENSE --
IN A LOBBYING BILL SEVERAL YEARS
AGO I WAS INTIMATELY INVOLVED --
IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE WE
WERE --
BROACHING SOME.
PICK CLEAR LINES WITHIN THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM THAT --
WOULD REPRESENT A KIND OF A A
FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN IN THE WAY
THE INDUSTRY WORKS.
AT THAT TIME WE ARRIVED AT THE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MARK RIGHT AND
AS I RECALL --
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THAT WERE TOO
NARROWLY FOCUS PROVISIONS OF
THIS LICENSE ON TO DO SO QUOTE
UNQUOTE SMALL GUY.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE ARTISAN
DISTILLER?
ARGOSY WERE SHIPPED OUT TO HER
--
FIFTY THOUSAND WELL WHERE DO YOU
ALL IN ALL DIRECTORS MOST OF THE
AUTHOR AND OR THE WITNESSES.
A PORT WHERE YOU ALL SEE.
THE INDUSTRY GOING ARE WE GONNA
BE BACK HERE THREE YEARS TALK
ABOUT [inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OR WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
WELL I WILL ALLOW THE WITNESSES
TO RESPOND BUT I DID WANT --
TO GIVE MY ACKNOWLEDGEMENT A
THANKS TO THE CHAIR.
FOR YOUR ROLE IN --
ADVANCING THIS INDUSTRY AND THAT
TYPE SEVENTY FOUR IS CREATED
WHEN -- A
TIME PERIOD I WAS OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY BEFORE IT CAME BACK TO
THE SENATE SORT REALLY GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND YOUR INTERACTION
ON THIS BILL BUT IN TERMS OF
WHERE THE INDUSTRY'S GROWN
GOING.
VERSES GROWING.
WE HOPE IT'S GROWING IN TERMS OF
NUMBERS OF BUT ON TERMS OF THEIR
QUANTITY I WILL ALLOW THE
WITNESSES TO RESPOND TO THAT.
ONE I DON'T KNOW IF PERSON YOUR
LANCE I'D I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT I
I HOPE THAT IF WE'RE BACK HERE
IN THREE YEARS IT SO THAT WE CAN
ALL BE CELEBRATING ALL THE
WHILE.
S. THAT WERE IN JOINING TOGETHER
--
BY AS MUCH AS I ENJOY COMING TO
THE CAPITAL --
AYE RIGHT THE IDEA OF TRYING TO
PUSH SOMETHING NEW THROUGH JUST
DOESN'T.
DOESN'T APPEAL AT ALL --
I WOULD.
I WOULD SAY THAT.
MY HOPE IS THAT AT THIS HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND GALLON LEVEL
WHAT IT DOES IS IT DOES
EQUIPMENT EVERYONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTILLERS WITH WHAT
THEY NEED TO BECOME.
MEANINGFUL PLAYERS --
AND BE ABLE TO EXIST AND BECOME
ATTRACTIVE TO DISTRIBUTORS --
I DON'T YOU DE [inaudible]
CENTRAL CHEERS AND THROUGHOUT
THAT ENTIRE TIME WE'VE WE'VE
WORKED WITH OUR DISTRIBUTORS WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
DISTRIBUTORS AND THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL OF SUCCESS IN OUR BUSINESS
THAT I ATTRIBUTE TO OUR
DISTRIBUTORS.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT EARLY IN
OUR HISTORY --
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH BETTER
OFF WITH THESE LAWS --
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE A
MUCH BETTER PARTNER TO OUR
DISTRIBUTORS RIGHT NOW HAD THAT
OCCURRED.
I THINK ABOUT OTHER STATES WITH
THESE THINGS HAVE OCCURRED AND
WHERE WHERE THERE ARE MUCH MORE
LIBERAL LAWS TO TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO MARKET AS A SMALL THE
STILLER.
AND THE DISTILLERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE UNDER THOSE SMALL
DISTILLER CAPS THAT ARE THAT
ARE.
IN MANY CASES MUCH HIGHER THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
GALLONS THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
HERE.
THEY ARE GREAT PARTNERS TO THEIR
DISTRIBUTORS EVERYWHERE BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GENERATE
ENOUGH REVENUE. TO BE ABLE TO GO
OUT HEALTH THEIR DISTRIBUTORS
MARKET THEIR PRODUCTS IN OTHER
STATES THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE CALIFORNIA POT PRODUCTS.
BE POINTS OF PRIDE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND IT AROUND THE WORLD.
SOME EDITOR BUT THAT TO ME WE'VE
MISSED THE MARK ON THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN THE FIRST DRAFT AS
FAR AS A ACADEMICALLY VIABLE
MODELER.
ON DUTY FOR SOME OF THE SMALLER
--
DISTILLERS THAT WORK IT'S IT'S A
PART OF IT IT'S ALSO IT'S ALSO A
TESTIMONY TO HOW DYNAMIC THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY IS RIGHT NOW AND
HOW THAT THE LANDSCAPE IS
CHANGING AT THE DISTRIBUTOR
LEVEL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
LA THOUGHTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WOULD I ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM.
LET'S SAY GO AHEAD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM NOW THAT MISTER GORE
USER.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GOING [inaudible]
THERE [inaudible]
BIGELOW PRESENT [inaudible]
ACOSTA HERE [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON HERE
GLORIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SALAS WALDRON.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT --
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
BEFORE US S. B. LEVELS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS.
GREAT AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
COOPER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON ARE GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
THINK.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WILL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY AYE GRAY I'VE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I DON'T SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SO IT'S AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED AT THIS TIME --
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE. TO
ITEM --
ELEVEN CENTER BY THAT IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE APPROACH AND
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
TODAY OF THE FIVE SEATS ON THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION ONLY THREE OR FILLED
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
ASK YOUR ABA.
JERRY BROWN AND ON BEHALF
ELECTED CHANCES CASINO PINNACLE
CASINO RANCHERS CLUBS YOU KNOW
MERCED CASINO MADERA STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS.
MISTER COOPER I GOT SOME
QUESTIONS SO THE FIVE BOARD
MEMBERS OPEN BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND I GUESS MY ISUES GOVERNOR
APPOINTS A FIVE MEMBERS.
AND HAVE BEEN VICTIMS FOR AWHILE
BUT SINKING ELECT A OR B.
SELANNE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS THE PUBS
THE GOVERNOR SO.
THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE THAT
CHANGES THE REQUIREMENTS.
OF THERE BACKGROUND BUT
SUBSTANTIALLY DOESN'T COVER.
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTING MEMBERS
THAT BOARD.
YET THAT IS CORRECT BUT AGAINST
ME GIVES HIM MORE OPTIONS SO
YOU'RE NOT JUST STUCK WITH ONE
PARTICULAR.
IN A FIELD.
MY I GOT MY BUT WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO HELP THEM ALONG A
MINUTE AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR HERE.
FIRST GOT HELP YOURSELF.
YOU MEAN THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
BUT YOU'RE GOING CLOSE SESSION
QUITE OFTEN AND YOU HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO DO WITH MONEY
LAUNDERING.
BUSINESS ISSUES LAW ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE SO IT HELPS IN CLOSED
SESSION TO HANDLES EXPERTISE
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS THE REQUIRED BY THE
VARIOUS COMMISSIONERS.
MAY BRING THEIR WIDE SPECTRUM OF
EXPERIENCE AND BACKGROUNDS NAM.
ALSO WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT YOU
WANT A FULL TO APPLY THEIR
CANDIDATES HER APPLYING THAT
HAVE --
CRIMINAL BACKGROUNDS BEEN
ARRESTED BEFORE SLEEP DEAL WITH
THAT'S WHAT'S IMPORTANT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
TESTIMONY IS SCI FI APPLICANTS.
A PACKAGE YOU REFLECT ON THEIR
LAW ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE AND
ALSO OFFER TO PROCEDURES AND
ALSO FINANCE --
SUPPORT HAVE SOME IN FINANCE IS
LIKE IF YOU HAVE A GROUP OF FIVE
INDIVIDUALS FULLER CT OURS THE
CHARTER CURRENCY TRANSACTION
REPORTS HE'S BEEN OVER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS GOT REPORTED.
I KNOW THAT OUR FINANCIAL CRIME
SO FOR ME HAVING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE TRAINED IN
THOSE VERY SPECIFICALLY.
THAT'S THAT'S CRITICAL SO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
FOLKS WITH THAT WITH THE
EXPERTISE WITH ME AUGUST ALLOW
THE SYMBOLS CONFLICTED WOODY
INVOLVES MONEY LAUNDERING.
AND THE TRAIL IS FOLLOW THE
MONEY AND WE FOLLOW MONEY IS
WITH FORCE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
BEARINGS AND FINANCIAL
EXPERIENCE LIKE A SAID IN THE
OWN STAFF REPORT [inaudible]
IT SAYS.
WHILE WE'RE THAT'S MEMBERSHIP
REQUIREMENTS COULD CERTAINLY
HELP FOR THE VACANT SEATS THIS
BILL COULD ALSO HAVE AN UNFIT
CONSEQUENCES OF DIMINISHING THE
DIVERSE PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUNDS.
PERSPECTIVES OF THE GAMING
COMMISSION SO YOU COULD I FLY
WORKERS ON THERE.
ENOUGH NOT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BUT THE ROUTE PALMER THIS IS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE FOLKS THERE.
YOU KNOW AND ORGANIZE CRIME WERE
COLLECTIVELY BECAUSE THE CHANCES
THERE.
INVOLVED THIS TYPE OF ACTIVITY
SO I GUESS EXPERTISE COMES INTO
PLAY EXPERTISE IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE DATE GOES
BACK TO YOU THE ADMINISTRATION.
IS FILLED WILL POINTS PEOPLE
THAT'S NOT JUST COMMISSION IF A
WIDE VARIETY OF COMMISSION BOARD
STATEWIDE.
THAT CAN'T FEEL THEY CAN'T FILL
SO.
TIMMY THAT'S THROUGH THE PROBLEM
CHANGING THAT NERVOUSLY MAKE UP
THE BOARD SO.
I'M I'M NOT CONVINCED BEING IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS THE GOOD REASON TO
CHANGE THIS EXPERTISE NEED FOR
THAT REASON.
THAT'S I LOVE TO HEAR YOUR
COMMENTS ON THAT.
LIKE.
WE JUST DISAGREE AYE I THINK
HAVING THAT HAVE NOBODY THERE IS
WORSE THAN.
HAVING QUALIFIED PEOPLE BUT IT
GOES BACK TO THE FUNDAMENTAL
POINT.
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTS THE PEOPLE
SO YOU MAY STILL HAVE THAT
PROBLEM IS NOT FROM LACK OF PURE
PLAY ATTORNEYS OUT THERE.
PLENTY OF RETIRED COPS OUT
THERE.
IN THE FINANCIAL PERSONS OUT
THERE SO AS FAR AS THAT SPECIFIC
BILL SPECIFIC AREAS OF EXPERTISE
ARE PUTTING OUT THERE.
AND IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF
APPLICANTS IT'S JUST LACK OF
APPOINTING THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT'S THAT'S TO ME THAT'S WHERE
THE BIG ISSUE [inaudible]
CONDITIONAL LA.
MR HUBER FRAME A THIS WAS A
ENABLE THE GOVERNOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO APPOINT MORE
QUALIFIED PEOPLE AS YOU'RE
POINTING TO RIGHT NOW WE ONLY
HAVE ONE LAW ENFORCEMENT SEE.
THIS WOULD GIVE HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY IN COURT MORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE WITH
BACKGROUND YOU'RE EXACTLY
DESCRIBING RIGHT NOW WE'RE
LIMITED TO ONLY ONE MEMBER.
WAS JUST GIVING THAT CALL OF THE
THE ABILITY FOR THE MOST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE AT THAT TIME.
WOULD YOU KNOW GREATLY HELP FILL
THE SEATS SO VERY MEANS MCHALE'S
BECAUSE THE LACK OF A QUORUM --
TO THIS POINT NOW KNOW SO WE'RE
ONLY THREE SO NUMBER ONE NO
REASON BEEN CANCELED.
SO AND GOES BACK TO YOU DON'T
NEED A BUDGET COPS ON THERE ARE
MUCH RETURNEES ARE A BUNCH OF
FINANCIAL.
BACKGROUND INDIVIDUALS DOWN
THERE YOU KNOW ONE FROM EACH SO
ELECTRICITY GOES BACK.
TO THEY ARE NOT HELD A MEETING
CANCELED EVER.
BECAUSE OF LEVEL POORLY STILL ME
SO.
IT COMES OUT FUNDAMENTALLY.
THE GUNNERS GOT APPOINT PEOPLE.
THAT THAT'S THROUGH THE PROBLEM
AYE YOU I DON'T CARE ABOUT
SAYING I'M NOT FROM OF FREE
THAT.
SO APPOINT THE PEOPLE IS SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
SO UP TO NOW HASN'T BEEN A
PROBLEM SINCE LIKE ANSWER
LOOKING FOR PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE IT HAD THE MEETINGS SO I
THIS IS I MEAN TO ME IT'S A AND
BILL LOOKING FOR AN ANSWER SO I
DEFTLY NON SUPPORTER THIS
[inaudible]
MISTER GORE.
BIGGEST CHAIRMAN ED MAY FALL A
LITTLE BIT OF MY COLLEAGUES OF
QUESTIONS --
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT ANY
DISCUSSIONS YOU HAD OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ABOUT THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL I RECOGNIZE THE
PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE.
THEM CURIOUS THEIR EXPERIENCES.
IT IS HARDLY A STATE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE YOU CAN FIND OF
FOLKS WHO CONSERVE OUR ON THIS
COMMISSION SO WHAT WHAT WAS
THEIR ANSWER FOR THE CHALLENGES
FROM PHILLY NEEDS VACANCY.
ALMA I SPOKE ABOUT THESE CHANGES
ON THE FEEDBACK I GOT WAS THE
FOR GREATER FLEXIBILITY WOULD
WOULD HELP AND THEY'D BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GREAT OF
FLEXIBILITY --
ANOTHER ISSUE --
WE COME TO NOTE AND DISCUSSED.
IS THE ADDITIONAL INCOME RIGHT
NOW YOU HAVE A COMPLETE
PROHIBITION ON OUTSIDE
EMPLOYMENT --
SO MANY OF THESE PEOPLE IN THESE
CERTAIN --
SPECIFIC AREAS HAVE OTHER
BUSINESSES OR OTHER JOBS AND
THAT REALLY RESTRICTS THEM FROM
APPOINTED SO IF YOU FOR EXAMPLE
OUT OF BUSINESS UNRELATED --
TO GAMBLING'S FOR EXAMPLE REAL
ESTATE BUSINESS YOU WOULD BE
PRECLUDED FROM FROM TAKING THAT
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT ADDRESSING UP.
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
IT WISE IN ADDRESS THE BILL NOW.
I'M JUST SOMETHING THAT THAT
CAME --
THROUGH DISCUSSIONS THAT THEY
CAN ARE OUR EYES BUT WOULD BE
WELCOME WORKING WITH --
THE CHAIRMAN AND PEOPLE TO
ADDRESS THAT IN THE NEAR FUTURE
[inaudible]
A FIRST GLORIA YOU CAN CALL IT
WHAT IT BASICALLY MEANS THAT I
NOTICED THAT IS WHY MATCHING
ALTHOUGH I I WOULDN'T.
LEAVE THIS BUILDING SO ANYONE
THAT HUNDRED FORTY GRAND YEAR.
IS NOT ENOUGH TO IT TO GET BY
UNDER UNDER FORTY TWO THOUSAND
THEY CANNOT AFFORD.
AS FOUNDING DOWN OKAY THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE IT IF IT WOULD FIT
ONE FORTY ONE FORTY TWO BY THE
WAY THAT'S THAT'S A HECK OF A
LOT MORE THAN MOST MY
CONSTITUENTS MAKE SO.
IT -- BUT
YOU KNOW IF THAT'S A THAT'S A
CONCERN TO ME EACH PARTICULAR
THE WHOLE ISSUE.
I DO QUIBBLE LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
OF THAT THE MATISSE BECAUSE I
THINK ON A NONPROFIT BORDER
RIGHT THIS IS A NONPROFIT WITH A
GOOD BOOK FOR GOVERNANCE YOU DO
HAVE PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS --
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY LOADED UP
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL.
ABILITY BUT DAMN IF AYE IF THE
POINT AUTHORITIES HAVING
DIFFICULTY YOU'D BE INTERESTING
TO HAVE A BABY POLY BETTER HAVE
A BILL THAT ADDRESSES ALL THAT.
I HEAR YOU CENTER YOUR INTEREST
IN TAKING THAT UP IN AN AND A
FUTURE COMMITTEE.
NONE DID I I'M NOT ADVOCATE I'M
I'M JUST I'M ASKING FOR BEFORE
THIS GETS TO THE FLOOR MAYBE
SOMETHING I CAN'T SUPPORT YOU
KNOW EXACERBATED TODAY --
YOU TO IS THAT IS THAT YOU
INTEND TO FURTHER AMEND THIS TO
TIM REMOVING A MORE POLITICIANS
OFF A HOSTILE ACT AS A
COMPOSITION.
WE ALWAYS HAVE AN OPEN MIND BUT
I I THINK RITE NOW OF THE WAY
THE BILL IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO FORWARD WITH THAT TODAY.
AND WE CAN ALWAYS YOU KNOW.
WE GET WE ARE GONNA HAVE A NEW
GOVERNOR MAYBE HE'LL GET ON THE
STICK AND ACTUALLY POINT SOME
PEOPLE.
COOPER YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
JERRY MEDICAL CERTAINLY THAT
CONCLUDE THE DISCUSSION WAS AND
I I TEND TO SHARE --
SOME OF THE SENTIMENT.
THAT BOTH MISTER COOPER MISTER
GOREY RAISE THAT THERE I'M NOT
SURE THIS BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
--
DRAFTED --
IS THE PERFECT SOLUTION I THINK
DIRECT INDIA ISSUE AS IT RELATES
TO OUTSIDE EMPLOYMENT.
IS A VALID ONE IS WELL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LIMITING OUR POOL
--
AND THAT'S NOT TO DISAGREE WITH
MISTER GORE THE HUNDRED FOR TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IS A LOT OF
FUN.
MONEY OUT FOR POSITION BUT IN
FACT IT ALSO DOES LIMIT.
THE POOL OF INDIVIDUALS ARE THEY
GAGE THIS ACTIVITY I'M ALSO NOT
ENTIRELY CONVINCED THAT --
SOMETIMES GOVERNOR'S JUST START
FOCUSED --
IN ALL AREAS THAT THEY NEED TO
BE FOCUSED WHEN IT COMES THEIR
APPOINTMENTS AND FOR SOME REASON
WAIT TILL THE FINAL MONTHS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE A LOT
OF APPOINTMENTS --
THAT'S ABOUT ISSUE AS WELL
[inaudible]
SO.
ALL THAT BEING SAID I GIVE YOU
TWO OPTIONS ONE YOU CAN KEEP THE
BILL HERE TODAY WE CAN KEEP
WORKING ON IT.
OR WE CAN --
YOU'LL HAVE MY SUPPORT TODAY AND
WE CAN --
WORK ON IT YOU KNOW --
AS IT.
CONTINUES TO MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND SEE IF WE CAN'T
PERHAPS --
ADD SOME REFINING TOUCHES TO
THIS LEGISLATION I'M VERY
PLIABLE [inaudible]
OKAY.
MY FAVORITE KIND SENATOR.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION OR SECOND.
WE HAVE MOTION IN THE SECOND
[inaudible]
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS DUE PASSED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS OKAY.
I GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA [inaudible]
I ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER NO.
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY I LACKEY AYE
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON.
THAT BILLY NEEDS --
WHAT ADDITIONAL VOTE WILL GO
AHEAD LEAVE DR ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THINKCENTRE?
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE TO SENATOR DODD.
WHICH IS ITEM. FIVE ON THE
AGENDA.
S. B..
NINE SEVENTY THREE WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MISTER BIGELOW A
SECOND FROM MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SENATOR DODD PLEASE PROCEED S.
B. TO USE NINE SEVENTY THREE
TAKES A TWO PRONGED APPROACH TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF DRUNK
DRIVERS ON CALIFORNIA'S ROADS --
THE CHP DESIGNATED DRIVER
PROGRAM EDUCATES THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF DRINKING
AND DRIVING --
THIS IS AN EXPANSION OF A
PROGRAM STARTED LAST YEAR'S EVE
BE SEVEN ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW THAT SAYS BITERS BARS
AND SUPPORT.
I HAVE WITH ME TODAY JOHN
LATTIMER.
SHERMAN MEMBERS JOHN MY MOM KEPT
YANZHOU THE WORLD'S LARGEST AND
LEADING DISTILLED SPIRITS
MANUFACTURER WITH THE MOTION THE
SECOND I WOULD JUST SAY WE
SUPPORT BOTH PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL THANK FOR MUCH.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINE MAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
US ONE SUPPORT THINK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
SAYING THAT ANY TESTIMONY NOT
POSITION.
SEEING NONE IT WILL BRING ABOUT
TO THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS THIS IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
I GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I HAD WATER GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS I LOST [inaudible]
COST [inaudible]
I HOUSE THAT I CENTER THAT BILLS
OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ITEM THREE ON THE
AGENDA.
WELCOME TO SENATOR [inaudible]
JACKSON
.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISSION JONES SAWYER. TO SECOND
FROM MISTER BIGELOW.
NOW I'M NOT SURE WHAT TO DO SHOT
HERSELF MIGHT BILL ARE SHALL I
COULD WELL I THINK I'M A HINT.
CRUDE ONES ATTENTION JOINT.
ODD JUST I'LL BRIEFLY MENTION
THIS IS A BILL THAT WILL GIVE
COUNTIES THE OPTION TO
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLLED COUNTY
RESIDENTS INTO A LOCATION BASED.
EMERGENCY OTIFICATION PROGRAM.
A WHILE PROTECTING RESIDENTS
PRIVACY AND PRESERVING THEIR
ABILITY TO OPT OUT OF THE
PROGRAM AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS GOING
FORWARD.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST I THINK
EUGENE HURST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
AS YOU ARE ALL AWARE VENTURA
COUNTY EXPERIENCED OF THE THOMAS
FIRE RECENTLY I AND AT THAT
POINT SET OUT NINETY THOUSAND
NOTIFICATIONS WITHIN 97%
COMPLETION RATE.
HOWEVER WHEN THE FIRE BROKE OUT
IN -- IN
VENTURA COUNTY LESS THAN 30% OF
THE COUNTY'S RESIDENTS HAD
SIGNED UP TO RECEIVE COUNTY
GENERATED CELL PHONE AND EMAIL
ALERTS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT SYSTEM THE
VENTURA COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY STAFF SPENT HOURS CALLING
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS WHO RECEIVE
PUBLIC SERVICES INCLUDING FOSTER
PARENTS SENIORS.
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
NOTIFYING THEM OF THE NEED TO
EVACUATE.
AS U. NO NOTIFICATION IS A
CRITICAL TOOL TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF COUNTY RESIDENTS
DURING A DISASTER ESPECIALLY ONE
SUCH AS THE FAST MOVING THOMAS
FIRE. FOR THESE REASONS OTHER
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD SUPPORTS SP
EIGHT TWENTY ONE WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN BROKE
COUNTY REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA
WE REPRESENT THE THIRTY FIVE
RURAL COUNTIES.
AYE IN CALIFORNIA MANY OF THEM
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THE FIRES
LAST YEAR --
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN I WILL ONLY
SAY THAT WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
GOOD BILL IT'S REASONABLE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS.
ARE NOTIFIED IN A TIMELY MANNER
THAT THEY NEED TO EVACUATE LAST
YEAR ABOUT.
AND I MIGHT INDICATE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AS AUTHORS
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JASON I COULD WITH IDLE
STINK GILBERT ROBESON SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
THANKS TO THE YOUR STAFF.
INTO THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KELLY JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY OUR
THANKS TO FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS REGARDING --
I OWE YOU LIABILITY THANK YOU.
OKAY A TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND MEMBERS THIS IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
BONTA BONTA AYE COOLEY.
LEE I COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY TIME DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON.
THAT DOES NOT SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AND I'M GOING TO REVEL IN THIS
MOMENT.
OKAY MEMBERS --
LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING --
FOR YOUR RECORDS S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY THREE BRADFORD HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA.
OKAY MEMBERS WE'VE ARRIVED AT
OUR FINAL ITEM ON THE AGENDA.
S. B. FIVE THIRTY ONE CENTER
GALGIANI.
SERGEANTS TO WE HAVE THE SENATOR
ON HER WHERE SHE WE RESCHEDULE
THAT FOR NEXT WEEK [inaudible]
OKAY.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A BILL ON
CALL THAT IS --
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN VIED ACT
ITEM --
ELEVEN WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
COOLEY.
I KNOW MORE.
THEIR ELEVEN OKAY.
I EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GLORIA NO [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
WALDRON.
OKAY MEMBERS THAT --
THAT BILL STILL UNCLE
[inaudible]
TWENTY SENATOR
LOVE.
OKAY MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE ITEM.
ELEVEN THIRTEEN THIRTEEN BOB
CALLED -- WE
WILL OUR CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
UP.
LOW I RUBIO AND WALDRON.
WHAT YOU'RE NOT?
OKAY THAT GOES OUT MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA RETURNED
ITEM ONE ON OUR AGENDA.
S. B. FIVE THIRTY ONE CENTER
GALGIANI PLEASE --
APPROACH AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS S. B. FIVE THIRTY ONE
RELATES TO DECLARATIONS OF LOCAL
EMERGENCIES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONLY CITIES
AND COUNTIES CAN DECLARE A LOCAL
EMERGENCY.
THIS BILL IS A TECHNICAL MEASURE
WHICH WILL CLARIFY THAT LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN DECLARE
A LOCAL EMERGENCY IMPORT
DISTRICTS.
LOCATED WITHIN THEIR LIMITS SOME
PORTS SUCH AS THE PORT OF
STOCKTON AND UNIFIED PORT OF SAN
DIEGO.
HAVE TERRITORIAL LIMITS WHICH
SPAN ACROSS MULTIPLE CITIES AND
COUNTIES.
THIS CAN MAKE DECORATIONS OF
LOCAL EMERGENCIES COMPLICATED
SHOULD ONE OCCUR.
S. B. FIVE THIRTY ONE WILL GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE NECESSARY
TOOLS TO APPROPRIATELY RESPOND
TO EMERGENCIES HERE TO TESTIFY
IS JASON JASON GONZALEZ.
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT OF
STOCKTON I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHASING
THEMSELVES REPRESENTING THE PORT
OF STOCKTON A VERY BRIEFLY THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO ADDRESS THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
GOVERNANCE.
OF THE PORTS WHICH AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED --
COULD SPAN SEVERAL JURISDICTIONS
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IN
THE COMMITTEES --
THIS IS WHERE IS WAY OUT MOTION
FROM MISTER COOLEY AND A SECOND
FROM MISTER GIPSON.
AND OVER WHAT THE PARTIES ANDY
ADELSON SUPPORT.
THE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL ARE ANY TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION RATHER.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
MISTER BIGELOW.
JUST CURIOUS --
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE LAW
ALREADY GIVES THIS --
POWER TO THE LOCAL AGENCIES THIS
IS A GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY.
WHAT'S THE REAL PURPOSE FOR THE
REQUEST TODAY.
MISTER BIGELOW IF I MADE CHASING
AND SALAS AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
POOR STOCKTON.
MOST SPORTS WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE FOR INDEPENDENT PORTS
SPECIAL DISTRICT PORTS.
ARE DEPARTMENTS OF THE CITY IN
THIS CASE THE PORT IS NOT A
DEPARTMENT OF THE CITY SO THIS
GIVES THEM THE AUTHORITY AS A
CITY WOULD.
HAVE THAT AUTHORITY TO DECLARE
THE EMERGENCY.
SO IT'S EXPANDING IT TO THE FOR
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICT
PORTS.
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE RECOGNIZE.
AS A LOCAL AGENCY.
KNOWN AS THE GOVERNMENT AND I
HAS THE SAME.
STANDING UP POWERS THAT'S WHEN
CONFUSED HERE A LITTLE BIT.
WHEN WHEN I STE?
WHEN I READ THIS I AND AND
REMEMBER MIGHT?
THE BASIC DAYS OF IT BEING A
SUPERVISOR SPECIAL DISTRICTS
HAVE LEGAL STANDING.
HELP ME OUT THERE PARTNER
STANDING IS THE THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS UNDER THE HARBORS A
NAVIGATION CODE DO NOT HAVE THIS
AUTHORITY AND WHICH IS THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO EXPAND
THE AUTHORITY TO THE FORCE.
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
UNDER THE HARBORS NAVIGATION
CODE.
WELL APPARENTLY THERE MUST BE
SOME AMBIGUITY SO I'M WILLING TO
HELP SUPPORT THIS --
BUILT FOR THE CLARITY BUT AGAIN
I THINK IT'S OR YOU.
UNDERSTOOD AND RECOGNIZED.
I'M WILLING TO HELP AND SUPPORT
THAT.
MR BICU I THINK THE ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION IF I UNDERSTOOD
YOUR QUESTION I WAS THAT UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA MERCHANT SERVICES
ACT.
ONLY CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
IT WAS.
PARTLY AND TRUE BUT ALSO THERE
THERE IS A SECTION IN THERE.
IF YOU REALLY GET DOWN INTO THAT
THE CODE.
THAT GIVES SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
ENTITIES SUCH AS YOUR HARBORS.
BUT THAT'S WHY THERE'S AMBIGUITY
HERE THAT'S WHY I'M WILLING TO
CLEAR THAT UP SO THAT WE HAVE
IT.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND --
MEMBERS THIS IS DUE PASS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GREAT AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA BY ACOSTA AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON --
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO.
LOW AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SO THIS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON I'M.
CENTER THAT BILLS OUT THINKING.
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR TWO
MINUTES FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON A
TIME [inaudible] SIX ON LIKE
[inaudible]
WHAT EXACTLY YEAH [inaudible]
NNOVA [inaudible]
BOB [inaudible]
RIGHT
.
YEAH CULTIVOS BASEBALL BATS YEAH
COMBINED.
WE SHOULD. TO BUY FOOD
[inaudible]
NOW YOU [inaudible]
THOUSANDS [inaudible]
I
THE COMMITTEE ADJOURNED